[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I love that smell I'm the guy who I go
to the grocery stores yeah and there's
always if there's a you know if it gets
puffy from the the off-gassing on coffee
I squeeze it out and I go because then
you get that smell and then once all the
air is out you can't squeeze it anymore
you ready the coronavirus but no I don't
spare the coronavirus I don't I did that
by licking the the salt lamps at Bed
Bath & Beyond salt lamps no I told you
that story really in bed bathroom yeah
oh you did yes oh do remember we have
salt lamps and then they have a lamp
assault Lin do you know the story I
don't think I've heard those then they
have a salt lamp that tell a story
quarantine is a promo code quarantine is
a hashtag we're doing a lot of kind of
that comes to us schedule we're doing
two shows a day because we want to best
serve you of course in this quarantine
which from any of you could be ending in
the next couple of weeks
fully so we've enjoyed spending time
with you and we'll be doing life advice
in a little bit so that was a board at
the importance of licking salt it's a
lamp
but this lamp in particular has
perfectly spherical okay very much
unlike the earth if you go up in a
helicopter so it's like a bulb and it's
a basket with a bunch of like perfect
yeah
like ice balls but Himalayan sea salt
okay Himalayan sea salt I don't know
their mountains Himalayan pink salt pink
salt sea salt Himalayan things the point
is I was looking I was like wow on that
looks like almost like a massage balls
yes yeah maybe these aren't real they
just look like salt okay and my wife is
checking out something that would have
been you know far more adult right and I
look at those like well this can't be
this can't be this long before kronor by
the way okay before he's in the feds way
before so yeah and I went to see and I
swear to you I hear steven crowder it
was someone who worked at Bed Bath and
Beyond
and we both had to act like you didn't
just catch me licking the salt lamp
balls oh my gosh they were salty they
were out lamb did you buy that one so
you didn't infect anybody with I it was
a guilt bite it was a guilt I and I was
like I can't get the floor model I
really want this one because it's
something I just feel drawn to then you
gave it away at the office Christmas
party - quarter black okay so we're
going to get some life advice you can
send your is it info at life and what is
it I always ask no that's not it that's
life and letters go calm you're wrong
you're wrong
Drakken purple drank not good for your
short-term memory not at all
so here's my question for you everyone
talks about everyone talks about Donald
Trump's attitude right a lot of things
that he says and his tweets I will say
this with all of these press briefings
and in this pandemic it's a pandemic I
am kind of surprised as to how often
President Trump gets things right and I
want to know what you think about this
is it does seem like there are more sort
of like if he's taking a stab in the
dark he almost always hit something have
you noticed how he's been right about
it's no credit nearly all of these not
even predictions but some of these these
comments that he's made specifically the
ones that the media have targeted that
they've latched on to ultimately he's
been right about them and will go
through I guess are the top examples
here so let's kind of give you some
context the media of course they've said
that there's a trending today on Twitter
I don't know if it's at this exact
moment but I was trending all day but
things stopped airing these White House
press briefings because propagate why
would the media why would the media run
press briefings from the Oval Office
when they could have a fat gay guy talk
about them so uh let's do you think I
make this up here is the media sing me
to suffering these but the president
loves saying things like you know
there's a drug we've got it's very
effective it's approved already
everybody's gonna get it he loves saying
things like that because that would be a
lovely thing to be able to be running
the briefing instead of talk about
[ __ ] that's not true in which case
telling people a fairy tale like that is
cool so all of us whether you're a
member of the media or a US voter or
you're a citizen of another country
watching us live on scene international
by man all of us have to see it for what
it is these are storytelling sessions
these are infomercials more than
accurate sources of information he
should return to his bed and cry for
days on end because of yeah kovin
reporting
we need another reset i cried them to my
bed and cried with my wife this by the
way isn't a white supremacist symbol it
means I don't believe it's remarkable
how many times that Trump has gotten it
right so here's let's go through one
here the this week I think particular
was at this week last week they all blur
together especially when two shows the
day the media trying to say that
President Trump started a feud with
governors saying that states we've read
this that states themselves should help
ramp up testing well the u.s. is
reporting more than 700,000 cases of
coronavirus nationwide as states began
to weigh when to relax social distancing
measures a key issue in that decision is
testing for Co vid 19 President Trump
says he's providing enough help for
states to make their own choices but
some governors say the federal
government needs to ramp up test kits it
comes as protesters in Virginia
Minnesota and Michigan are demanding an
end to quarantine while the president
appears to be egging them on journalism
appears to be egging them on the
president appeared to have requested
leggo my eggo just I despise these
people they're communists just to be
clear even mister nipple bärbel himself
while they were talking about governors
said that the president state this is a
long clip I warn you but it's worth it
unilaterally agreed with the president's
stance we've had conversations about it
the president is right right states have
to do what they have to step up on
testing and the federal government has a
step up on testing federal government
involved in testing and they did a whole
presentation at the president's briefing
on testing and what they're doing on
testing what they're doing under and
that's great and between the states wait
til a rebuttal
government we will do the best job we
can
what was the president's tweet listen
this exactly just like I was right on
ventilators our country is now the king
of ventilators all the way great states
must do their part and the federal
government must do its part perfect
that's what's called partnership I agree
nein crap thing you know I understand we
have to sift through that till we get to
the a golden nugget
yeah and he's very agreeable all the
sudden it was just like I don't know
what what kind of dirt does Trump have
on him I don't know I know tapes down
his nipples so he's not getting the the
abrasions anymore
I just never my wildest dreams that we
think that a press conference with a
sitting governor would be reading a
tweet from a president and it sounded
like that was awesome for the King I
don't know if he's in fact the king I
vote for your keg of ventilators that's
what your king he was born that way the
lady came from the pond Ovid with the
ventilator and named B X ventilator King
so there's another one that Donald Trump
talked about and this is report as
Donald Trump's saying remember they said
Donald Trump said this will go away as a
miracle all of us warm weather well
it'll come and this will go that's not
what he said but again if you look at
something that he got it almost an
Oracle in the same because I didn't
think that he would be this good he
didn't say it'll go away like a miracle
what he did say is it maybe it would
decrease in April once we saw warmer
weather here's the quote the virus looks
like by April you know in theory when it
gets a little warmer it
miraculously goes away hope that's true
first off April it getting warmer in
April is not a theory yeah
to have it happen most years it's an
observable trick but I hope it gets one
man that's right but he says maybe it'll
go away
who knows and I'll come back to why
people shouldn't have dumped jumped on
Donald Trump they dumped in Donald Trump
who should've jumped on him so it's now
mid April in theories and Cuomo just
announced that deaths are declining of
course they declared New York State past
the peak which is a big thing for them
they needed they needed a win they
needed to win they need a big win
obviously our hearts go out to anyone
affected by chronovisor but also
particularly those who still have to
live in New York City yes still in New
York City a new study from the
government can we stress I want to be
sure that what's authoritative it now
shows us that coronavirus kovat 19
doesn't survive very long in high
temperature or high humidity and that it
is quickly destroyed by sunlight a
second study same linked warm and humid
weather in the past months to decrease
cases right and it showed that warmer
parts of the united states like texas
florida have seen a slower spread then
places like New York and Washington and
then there in that study as a matter of
fact I think we can bring us up they
determine that I think globally like 90
is it 90% do we have a 90% of
coronavirus cases have occurred in cool
climates between 37 to 63 degrees and
here's you think wow it's not like
President Trump needed some kind of a
crystal ball this isn't new this is this
Andy go back to the 1918 flu epidemic
doctors they used to like open-air
treatment because they noticed that
people in sunlight recovered more
quickly you've heard like sunlight is
the best disinfectant right not
necessarily
well sometimes pure grain alcohol but it
comes from like you know yeah warped
bones and you're coughing and you know
go west and we'll see what happens
Wow and by the way so I science I hadn't
seen that clip of what Trump actually
said but I had seen all of the headlines
and I was like ah that was a really dumb
thing to say now I see the clip I'm like
whoa that's not even what he said at all
but it is actually true I mean go figure
we have fewer cases of the flu every
single year in the south than we do in
the north and it's not just because a
population it's by per capita
right because it's colder up there for a
little bit longer and it just had it's a
natural thing come on
it would that's why it's surprise it
just shows you how Dead Set they're
ingesting on him on in other words if
they have dr. Sanjay Gupta can't find
out about the flu in 1918 right
he won't know about by EPA or rickets he
doesn't understand how UV light works as
a disinfectant seen the Hammacher
Schlemmer catalog with the toothbrush a
natasha that has UV light is that a real
thing yes that's real no idea my
sister-in-law bought me one for
Christmas how do you know it's very
inconvenient in theory so here's another
one that I just love is a young mr.
Rachel Maddow said that Donald Trump was
lying about about Navy hospital ships in
terms of the happy talk we've had on
this front from the federal government
there is no syllabi for hospital ships
that the president made such a big deal
of a comfort in the mercy there's no
sign that they'll be anywhere on sight
helping out anywhere in the country for
weeks yet president said when he
announced that those ships would be put
in an important action against the cove
in nineteen epidemic he said one of
those ships would be operational in New
York Harbor by next week that's nonsense
it will not be there next week and I
know that many of you out there don't
have well I guess you can watch things
on fast speed but I realize a lot of
young people don't really use a
fast-forward button anymore but they
skip on a timeline right by the way hey
Amazon Prime I would like to have a
speed if I'm going to fast forward a 9
minute
HBO intro that somewhere between half a
frame a second and DeLorean if there
could be in between that would be
wonderful I don't need to watch the
robot in the MILCON West world for four
minutes every time No so let's just
pretend like you have a fast-forward
here we're sitting weeks nothing so one
week here we go oh damn by the way one
week this is awesome people thought we
were going to have to wait many weeks we
did inch that dude Maddow
he only headed to wait one week here's
another one
Laura close Roxy chloroquine of course
you can see our reaching out and
coverage of the lady who drank fish tank
cleaner rather it was a democratic
governor and I think offed her husband
girl basket arias in basket the media of
course mocks Donald Trump mercilessly
and this is something Trevor Noah tatted
chloroquine he claimed that Donald Trump
mentioned he said it was a bull and I
think we have a clip bull here which is
ironic because it seems like Trevor Noah
does mention the difference between men
and a cure Donald Trump never claimed
that it was a cure that never ever ever
happened now if you don't like the fact
that Donald Trump claimed that it could
be a valuable treatment which by the way
is what we're looking for right now
because a cure is a ways off fine but he
never said it was a cure someone forgot
to tell mr. biracial Edmond Dantes
germinal Oh what we got the tree we're
gonna cure it we got him
what camera framing he was just making
that up what the president said was
either confusing or just plain wrong I'm
glad I wore my sweat pant cuz I can
check now it's so funny my trunk Wow
yeah inverted don't do that that's like
a shriveled-up number those California
Raisins when I used to be a band yeah
only they're not singing I was in the
unfunny
this is what bothers me so much about
Trevor Noah is he is you know you've
seen like people talk about to sellout
band yeah you've seen people talk about
like Pat prepackaged pre fried Trevor
Noah's absolutely not the best person to
that job when you know when you look at
the history of The Daily Show Jon
Stewart Stephen Colbert
Steve Carell Rob Riggle Rob Corddry who
else do we have that I already said Rob
Riggle what's the name of Ed Helms gosh
it's just a who's who of talent yeah and
the successor was Trevor Noah when you
think of the old late night war Rose
like Jay Leno at one point Joan Rivers
imagines they just threw like Milton
Berle in there he's gonna host a show he
would even go trick Trevor Noah get to
the back kid pick your spots
he's just the worst okay so after
people's comments
Governor Cuomo announced that New York
was running trials right and that
immediately the FDA approved the drug
for treating coronavirus and we've
already covered this many studies by the
way that the media never covered which
was remarkable to me because I would say
there's no science at all behind the use
of chloroquine we
have any evidence thus far other than 50
years of it other than many men and many
many studies at this point had come out
and showed a shocking efficacy rate
though they did then cover say see this
what we were concerned about the science
is in one flawed Brazilian study that
did show negative results with two
different sample groups from using a
significantly higher than recommended
dose so this brazilian study when people
try to quote and say look it can cause
all kinds of heart problems they had two
groups they people who used slightly
lower than the recommended dose and
they've continued that right under study
and then we had a group that used more
than the recommended dose and they had
to stop that so we had no science in
when we had result after a study after
study after study showing us that it
worked and then the one study that says
hey what happens if we use far more than
the prescribing would indicate well now
we have some science showing that it
doesn't work well I would say that the
media probably grabbed ahold of that
negative study was just blasting it all
over the place and not the positive
studies that we've had coming out day
after day after day after day and what
more reliable study more reliable yes
even even I think it was a Democrat
House member right from Michigan
yeah thanks Trump for hydroxychloroquine
she said that she felt better less than
two hours after taking the drug and
that's anecdotal but in fact this is why
doctors are using it in hospitals across
the carpet it still happened it's
anecdotal right if you're gonna put the
negative stuff that's pretty much
anecdotal as well I'm right is can you
at least include the positive the study
is help in the science show that it
works effectively as a treatment not as
a cure unfunny Noah and then of course
the anecdotal would indicate that as
well here's another quick one the
ventilators I will say because I thought
this was this was weird right New York
set up they would originally need I
think was at thirty thousand ventilators
yeah and they were upset that Donald
Trump only sent four thousand to New
York and the media accused Trump of
downplaying it and I remember thinking
was weird because he said they need
40,000 ventilators folks most hospitals
have a few I've never heard who needs
40,000 ventilators we may have to look
into what they're doing with these
ventilators people say oh you don't care
about people dying right and ever at
that time saying why are you picking
this fight Donald Trump if they say you
need 40,000 ventilators would just just
send them 40,000 ventilators they don't
have an excuse well it turns out that
creating a ventilator is almost like
creating a car and they didn't need it
at all the Blasio actually says now that
they're fine they only needed a fraction
of what they thought right they were
basically just gonna end up hoarding
ventilator and it was important for the
federal when you talk about the
appropriate role of federal government
and states it's necessary for the
federal governor
to have a stockpile that they can
provide to states right right and they
provided more than enough to New York so
that was another area where I thought he
was they have like this might not play
well for you
remarkable yeah and you can't you just
give all of your supplies to one state
you have to triage to the rest of the
country because we're all in this
together Robin I've heard people say
he's playing for DHS for D I've even
heard people go as far as saying that
he's playing five DHS Wow first let it
be known let the record show I were the
first on this program to state that he's
playing 7d chip what even happened to
six I skipped it Wow
I want to make sure that I left so
mister Matewan my wake okay masks this
was one that people it sounded silly
where he talked about sanitizing because
I think he said using five liquids and
reusing I have to tell you the they
throwing away of the mask being in
private business they're throwing away
the mask right away they're thrown away
and when you like four or five medium
masks world I'm saying fifty five
million how could it possibly be such a
number and they say oh that's just a
small fraction of what we need and I
said why are we sanitizing this you know
you look at the mess I've looked at all
the different masks some don't lead
themselves to doing that I think but
many do and I said why aren't we have
very good liquids for doing the
sanitizing the minute something they're
they're starting to do more and more the
sanitizing the masks and then rachel
maddow huge like the liquids he thought
he wanted a no bid contract for Trump
vodka just throw in the pile like there
isn't some kind of refuse like there's
no place for medical waste right it was
very reasonable yeah
but the highlight was fine liquid
because that does sound dumb it does
give you one for you sounds tough but
then of course the media said this was
absurd it was impossible it was
irresponsible
well now the FDA has cleared a private
nonprofit Battelle not to be confused
with Mattel trying with anything from
Mattel you'll just get kid germs on it
um
the tell kids start sanitizing masks
we'll probably have about eight hundred
thousand a day sanitized
and then now they even hired over 2,000
new texts to help and as of this weekend
they're actually expanding further to
sanitize all masks for first responders
for free so free enterprise works and
even then this is something we should
all be on board with recycling now masks
are reusable it should be a double win
but because President Trump said fine
liquids which sounds kind of dumbass ish
it does that's what the media covers
well I guarantee what they'll come out
and say is that those liquids are really
bad for the environment and that now
we're creating a problem right so Megan
can you where then we went to glass and
they're like that's what we need a
solution with aluminum bottles not cans
they're losing their market share to
craft breweries let's go here's an
aluminum bottle I thought but I thought
but I thought that I thought the
dolphins were getting caught in the
six-pack things like you know what we
don't really care let's just aluminum
bottles let's just skip it skip along
here hit the fast board watch it twice
speed and don't you know call us inertia
here's another one to travel ban this is
something that Donald Trump was very
clear about and travel from China Biden
claimed it was xenophobic and Bernie
said that he would keep borders open but
neither should we panic or fall back on
xenophobia or complete ascent labeling
Cova 19 a foreign virus does not
displace accountability for the
misjudgments that have been taken as a
teenager under that podium with not
least Academy administration if you had
to which there was an election going on
no no no what you don't want to do right
now we have a president who has a
propagated xenophobic anti-immigrant
sentiment from before he was elected
really anti-immigrant anti back virus
yes an anti illegal immigrant yeah anti
illegal but more specifically here more
so about the wet markets in the virus
you know that's really what banning all
of the places and doesn't want to
demonize anyone including people who
likely are carrying the disease coming
from the province where the disease has
originated but he does want to demonize
business owners yeah
if you make money we have no time for
you but they boil dogs alive on the to
go menu and put it in a box well you
know what listen let's be a little more
open mind here are people by the way
down Lao Chi since people have to call a
rock jockey said that it was of course
the right call and that it stopped us
from becoming another Italy that early
on they did not shut out as well the
input of infections that originated in
China and came to different parts of the
world one of the things that we did very
early and very aggressively the
president you know was put the travel
restriction coming from from China to
the United States and most recently from
Europe to the United States because
Europe is really the new China and
actually I wish we didn't cut the clip
so short because after that he did a
great rendition of got no strings to
hold me down oh wow that's hate that I
missed that yeah
no you don't by the way well we're
talking about science because
Republicans are apparently are the party
of anti science scientists they estimate
the travel restrictions in China alone
may prevent it 700 thousand cases wow
that's a lot no this is an actual
peer-reviewed study not an article in a
Chinese government popper propaganda
outlet or Rachel Maddow evening opinion
show well everybody goes to the the
China ban and that was it that was a
huge thing right but the the event well
yeah no but then the Europe ban he got
the same amount of crap for even the
people were like why are you banning us
it turns out most of the cases occur on
virus in New York came from Europe right
they traveled through to Italy and then
through the rest of Europe to New York
City most of them
well we suppose he was right again well
they wanted us believe it was racist so
now are we supposed to leave that he's
like from 1920s New York where he hates
those guineas yeah yeah he's just
closing up a he just can't know what
those jegos coming up a bear scared trip
take what with cheese if anything he's
banned so many he's been to so many
places with when you talk about the
Islamic fan which again was of course it
was targeted and it what this was
determined by Barack Obama I think was
sitting countries or seven countries and
then Donald Trump is your follow suit
right away followed suit like he hates
Muslims well then he hates he
Mexicans then there was a Honduran cat
Caravan where the Mexicans like canyons
like oh he hates onions and el
Salvadorians there like he hates the
Chinese and then he just banned traveled
from Europe where it's mostly white
people yeah it just doesn't like it
especially notwithstanding we know the
history there
I saw true romance that being said it's
an exception not the rule right we do
have to go to life advice here in a
second I want to know what you guys it
is remarkable to me because I do
understand that Donald Trump obviously
says things that come off as as not
particularly sharp that being said
compared with Joe Biden I'm amazed as to
how sharp he has stayed he really has an
age certainly mentally cognitively he's
boisterous he's bombastic he can be a
little bit of a bully a little bit of a
dick but he is the same today as he was
when he became present and he almost
seems to be getting sharper if you watch
don't take my word for it by the way
watch these briefings I encourage
everyone out there if the media won't do
their job I think tomorrow actually
Tuesday we'll be doing a press briefing
live stream party yeah so we'll be doing
the job that the press refuses to do
tomorrow whenever the briefing starts so
it's kind of a little bit fluid because
Donald Trump is pretty things doesn't
always show up he shows up now you
listen think of it I feel like he's a
Midwest auto salesman the king of Italy
my soccer game who are you Harry Chapin
so I amazed I think he's been doing an
unbelievable job and the more that I dug
into this I am surprised as to how many
predictions he made that he got right
watch the briefings for yourself there
are all kinds of channels that have them
available on YouTube right now and
that's this is where the wonder of new
media is actually valuable provided the
big tech overloads don't try and step in
and do start carrying the water forcing
an MSNBC NBC ABC CBS and pretty much
anyone everyone not named Fox News this
is a great time to actually take it
straight from the horse's mouth make
your own decisions don't take my word
for it like levar burton i would ask
that you take the word of a six-year-old
boy who recommends the coloring book
it's a pop-up okay let's go to life
advice
with guru Crowder but soothing sounds
sales injury you have a good voice for
radio oh no I was saying that was
soothing and a face but thank you for
ring the same that's the best compliment
I've been given us have a thing you have
can you do your best year old C
impression for us face I've been working
on it all making mother of my children
all right you can send yes to life and
about color and I this is the time of
the show where I tell you of course if
you are thinking about any sort of
self-harm or anything serious like that
any suffering from any serious
psychological psychiatric symptoms you
should always seek out professional help
anyway and I advocate therapy home use
with psychologists I think it's a good
thing we do our best that being said my
best is better than a doctor just facts
yeah I mean I just say best because we
haven't even come up with a term to
apply here yes true but most people say
you can see better than bassant you can
you're the blank around you fill it in I
don't know but I'm that yeah I'm a guru
that's the point that I'm getting at
here ah
we appreciate you sending in sending in
your letters and of course we get some
some videos so yeah we do of course
understand that you forgo all anonymity
yes anonymity anonymity all right a
minimun first one sea anemones yeah also
I never work I also know the word
stalactites Oh totally different things
select eyes they're in caves right below
them are what's a sea anemone I know she
was an honest question area I have no
idea I noticed a lack tide is I don't
know what a sea anemone is well those
are things that made me think of the
other word like those things would have
a little twinkling alright this is we've
integrals and stuff this has run its
course we have do you read okay
Crowder I recently came out of the
closet and started to date other gay men
yeah coming out hot
did you need a specified gay man I
thought that was redundant I mean you
start dating other men if they're not
gay then I mean get your ass back in the
closet
it's a wholesome place find yourself a
walk-in and stay there I am a
conservative who finds most of the
liberal propaganda to be both illogical
and downright dishonest I live in New
York and almost every day I go on at
some point the guy I'm dating will say
something like I hope Trump and anyone
who follows him gets coronavirus well
this seems pretty reasonable yeah I mean
this isn't plaguing you for all your
life I mean have you say like a long
time that maybe said swine flu or
sorrowed flu SARS man oh yeah sort of
pandemic inside yeah down to the point
of I value politics but I can also see
myself as someone who's open to debate
and enjoys growing together and
understanding each other's ideals that
being said I feel like I'm starting
every relationship with a secret inside
and it's almost like I'm having to come
out all over again as a conservative
well that's true a lot of conservatives
because apparently you can't like and
lower taxes no bleep that but it's taxes
thank you Jesus would want us to bleep
taxes lower taxes he had a problem with
the taxes but tax collectors same
playing field of prostitutes under under
Caesar
no no I'm talking about math you know I
know I'm just saying okay all right well
you know we can just say it's hard
enough being gay and having like 97% of
the population not available to you I
can't imagine also having to restrict
myself to only making sure I date
conservative guys which I might add I
have yet to see in NYC so far please
help me your advice on this PS you are
very handsome well that's very nice
I don't mind it I didn't mean it like
that trying to butter you up for it to
the vice mayor that doesn't mean so much
because let's be honest like it's a meat
market it's true the gays even if I
weren't handsome you'd want it guys
the magazine's everything out magazine
and everyone's like all these gorgeous
guys and women go why all these all the
good-looking ones taken it's hmm that's
not really representative of the entire
community have you heard of bears it's a
thing point is there are ugly people all
around there are polluting the gays but
I appreciate you saying that I am
handsome enough to go around is
nearsightedness something that plagues a
gay community I have no idea I don't
know I mean I know a lot of conservative
gay guys but I understand this just
because I work in this field but I do
know that there are a lot of groups that
exist where gay conservatives can sort
of congregate and Meetup
that might be not as easy to start yeah
yeah that's gonna happen just like we
were talking about with women like the
reason that conquest for women is seen
as some kind of an accomplishment
because all I need to say is yes exactly
engage the most decadent yes yes yes yes
okay the refractory period is insane I
don't understand like straight people
like sex but I don't think we can have
sex as much as gay people do you have a
problem you know if you don't want it to
all be about sex then don't make every
publication that you put out there all
about sex we assume that you're a gay
camping magazine anywhere if it was it
would be about sex camping you know
what's the equivalent like I don't know
there's gonna be the only advice that I
could give you is there are people out
there like you I think you'll see more
particularly in the area of Trump
because everyone's so much better there
can be people you might not find people
who share necessarily or your your
social values but you can find people
who at the very least understand your
your financial standpoint of gay people
who actually are pretty traditional no I
shouldn't say a lot but they exist and
they exist namely in the conservative
community and I could mean probably five
just off the top of my head in New York
City yeah well look I think it's the
same thing with any kind of relationship
trying to find somebody who matches with
you on a number of different components
of religion and you know kind of how you
feel morally even if you don't believe
in any God or value just overall right
so in this case I think you have to lead
with that kind of stuff I know it's
daunting but you have to get that out
there
if you're in New York City of a very
liberal place they like you said there's
don't like that probably plenty of
people out there that are conservative
but you can't just hide it you got to
come out each time and you have to you
have to be ready to answer the questions
and walk away trust me
there's gonna be another guy right for
this person it sounds a little weird but
there's plenty never men in this and if
none of that works consider playing for
you the team
yeah there's a much wider selection with
a much deeper bench we do far less aids
[Applause]
[Music]
submission video here we go
hi guru Steve and I have a question for
you my husband died he just got married
about eight months back and we've had
the you know normal issues that a
newlywed couple has was a couple of
Christians we know that marriage is for
life but the only issue that we really
run into is one of his friends that he's
had for a long time he convinced my
husband to get professional help for
depression and anxiety for which I am
forever grateful
but this friend doesn't could've be
arrogant and incredibly very far less
fellini he is also a Christian
technically ordained so should know that
humility is a necessity and Christian
likes but for some reason refuses to
first do it my husband and him share a
lot of interests and so my husband wants
to stay around to him because a lot of
his other friends most of his friends
are in this group - and if he drops this
guy and he has all of his friends go on
I'm gonna be a good wife and I want to
be a good teammate and I his mother and
forbid him from seeing his friends I
think that is good for men the bond of
men and I want to see him do that but
I'm scared of this friend that he has
and his influence I think he's one of
those people that are either really
stupid or evil
so someone people coarser than that or
if you get into but don't really have
the time
so she could give me some advice a girly
appreciative
well first off thank you for let me a
couple of things that you got right
first off adorable oh yeah just
wonderful your eyes really colored orbs
and I don't know it felt like if you
have makeup on but like you know I have
this skin that just just like I always
perpetually look 14 and there's just
pimples and grace I don't know how that
happens
I'm envious I shouldn't be but I'm
envious you get a lot right as well
wanting to be a good teammate one-port
your husband not his mom right something
what she said she's I don't want to be
his mother oh I thought you said like
his wife is not his mom I should hope
not
no we don't watch this show we don't
want people watching this show wait is
autobiographical and something I wanted
to touch on here that kind of track
record with me I appreciate you said
this friend helped your husband sort of
seek help for anxiety and depression and
here's something that may be a component
to this problem and you see this a lot
with sort of Christians and even people
who are sometimes just on the right wing
or who are anti medical establishment
we've talked about how people get pushed
to the fringes if they feel as though
they have no other options and you and I
have talked about how often in the
church a lot of times Christians are
like I am even if they're not against
any kind of psychiatric assistance or
pharmaceuticals they will somehow brag
whether they mean to or not I am NOT on
anything I just take fish oil I don't
take any drugs but it's okay for you
though it's oil but it's okay for you
though your that happens a lot yes or
not like just brain smarts I'm in like
no actually beneficial for depression
omega-3 factors yeah there are a lot of
things that do help it no it's not a
penisy it's not going to cure severe
depression all right so I do so before I
go forward and say this I am NOT Pro go
to drugs as your first option right I
think before anything else before you
get whether it's lap band or Zoloft
you need everything else in order what
do you need to do you get your spiritual
life in order as much as you can
physically you need to be going to the
gym you need to be exercising and you be
getting your diet in order and then if
that doesn't help and you still have
problems you go seek medical help some
people do all these things right and
then they find out that they have like
type 1 diabetes or they find out that I
have a thyroid condition and they take
that pill some people do everything
right and they're disciplined and they
do their daily devotionals and they do
meditation and they try to sleep right
and eat right
still find themselves depressed or they
still find themselves with crippling
anxiety it does happen and I don't want
to see conservatives the right-wing or
Christians push these people to the
fringes where the only options that they
have are to seek out pill pushers
because those people exist as well for
sure I think we need to be open-minded
and we need to be empathetic to people
who may be struggling with mental health
unfortunately it's often only discussed
when some celebrity kills himself and so
everyone comes out and says I struggle
with mental health but it seems a little
bit disingenuous so that may be why your
husband if this friend is the only one
who actually sort of spurred him to seek
out professional help your husband may
have a bond with him because this person
may have saved him a whole lot of
heartache or really may have improved
his life and not as a difficult bond to
break if he feels like this was the only
person who was able to help him so
that's kind of a macro point that I'd
like to make it larger I think we need
to be mindful of this on the other side
without knowing a whole lot about this
friend I would say this and then I'll
let Gerald take it from here you need to
be honest about yourself no I've always
said this your close circle of friends
people who confide in people who would
be offering you any marriage advice say
they cannot be people who don't share
your values they can be beer buddies
they can be guys you go play ping pong
with that's fine that cannot be people
who help you make your life altering
decisions if that is the case here
that's a problem and I think the only
way to fix it is you know your place a
bad habit with a good habit is you get
other better people in that circle of
friends better influences people who
share those values but I also think you
need to ask yourself is this someone who
is really corrosive to your marriage is
this someone who's really harmful to
your husband or is this someone who you
would rather your husband not hang out
well yeah that's a question that only
you can answer not saying that's the
case but I do think you need to take
some quiet time and and reflect on that
because I've seen both of those cases be
true yeah it seems I was wondering what
what other than being a leftist and not
being humble what the sins of this
person were right that's you those are
the only two things that you listed and
like all right somebody who's not humble
is annoying you know but I'm not sure
that that's something that I'm scared of
right now somebody being around but to
your wife be faithful to your wife yeah
you know honor your vows and then he
also happens to want socialized health
care that's annoying yeah
someone who doesn't understand logically
why that doesn't work but that doesn't
mean it's someone who needs to be cut
out of his life no not at all and it's
not like those are infectious ideas that
are just gonna obviously propagate to
your husband
right and change him it's like look it's
okay for I think this relationship to
still exist if it's an unhealthy
relationship for whatever reason then
obviously you need to be sparing your
husband on and just just bringing things
up like hey every time you come home
from hanging out with Johnny like you
say and I don't even know if the guy's
name is but you know you say like these
things and it never seems like it's a
positive but in a microwave or some SH
yeah some weird thing thank you that's a
great example for it so many cats but
also you're eight months into marriage
right and you have those things that you
go through and right I know this I am 10
months into marriage or actually a
little over that right now and these
things I think will kind of filter
themselves out too you'll start making
new friend groups as a married couple
that eventually I don't necessarily get
rid of old friend groups but some of
those old relationships were a first
season and this one may be one of those
yeah your husband may naturally kind of
work his way out so I would say take a
little bit of a hands-off approach to it
for now kind of see where it goes and if
it truly is harming your husband that's
a different conversation the way I think
we're having right right like I had some
my wife honestly didn't really have many
toxic relationships she doesn't always
pick your friends pretty well you can't
pick your family members so that's one
of those things that's sorry you just
have to take the L yeah but she has some
friends I did up to sort of delineate
like I didn't really want to hang out
with these friends but there was
annoying like she had a friend who was
kind of toothy okay that was it what
like little gummy a little gummy I was
wrong and had to check myself and I let
the process work itself out naturally
and she's like a shark to you what a few
states between you and from
yeah and if it is corrosive you think
about it and it really is a bad
relationship for your husband I have
talked to him right if sitting around
thinking about it and wondering about it
and you know we appreciate the question
coming here but yeah talk to him and I
would also say talk with ideally his
father talk with men whose values you
and your husband both share right and
also have them talk with your husband
now don't go I'm not saying gossip
around your husband's back but express
the concern to your husband so he knows
so it's not a surprise and then whoever
it is out there who you see having a
positive influence on your husband and
whose opinion your husband respects
particularly as a man not saying that
you're a pet your opinion should be the
most important to your husband but
sometimes an objective third party also
as a man can be very helpful yeah yeah
absolutely all right next one is you
Gerald all right perfect
esteemed guru Crowder mmm my wife and I
that's it goes without saying it does
yeah I mean it should say something else
instead I don't my wife and I have been
married for nearly a year now
hmm when it comes to sex I unlike align
myself disappointed or even frustrated
ooh
my wife suffers from chronic illness
which can leave her tired or disgruntled
and while I'm sensitive to her needs and
do not blame her it means that we often
go days without being intimate when we
do make love I can feel like the only
participant very rarely does she
initiate physicality like it and when
she does I still end up doing pretty
much everything I would appreciate your
input
well first off one like go see about the
intimate and everyone go stay yeah so I
don't know how old this person is I
don't think it's said but if you are I
think if you're a young person and you
have been looking forward to being
married and you've waited for sex and
then you get to this and it's like sex
has been built up in your mind as
something that's wonderful in marriage
right even if it's if it's kept
appropriate as this wonderful thing and
then you you encounter a situation for
whatever reason that's difficult it's
hard right you've got it you've got to
figure out how to be intimate with one
another in these situations and I'll say
this having a chronic illness that's
that's different than a random I have a
headache or we're too tired or something
like that it seems like that's something
that you knew going in that there was
this chronic illness and that there may
have been some impact from that I'm sure
this isn't the first time that this
verse a Shin has come up right even if
you weren't having sex before marriage
so I think you just have to figure out
how you work around that and you have to
give as much grace as possible because
this person can't do anything about a
chronic illness there's nothing that
they can do it other than wife's name he
didn't include it I didn't say it
although saying give it to grace as much
as Bono give them as much grace
really no don't not if she doesn't want
to because that's rape it's Jay so which
we don't condone no I agree with you
that being said this is the kind of
thing that would probably benefit from
couples counseling it would yeah and I
will say this I someone who my wife and
I waited to have sex with each other
until we were married it's very
different from a lot of other
relationships right you get a lot of
people talk about sexual compatibility
which is kind of silly if you're both
being selfless and you're both actually
assuming the other one first and putting
their needs first you should both and
it's like I had a pastor tell me it's a
like going out for Chinese food every
once you get a fortune cookie but I hate
fortune cookies but I like orgasms so it
wasn't a very good thing about this for
a second it is between married couples
and Christians I'll talk about this you
it creates a bond two flushes become one
we talked about this biblically it is
something that creates an intense
connection a soul tie if you will and
you get to have orgasms it's wonderful
sex is a great thing and for people who
wait until they're married to have sex
sometimes people go oh well the reason
that's people don't have the same kind
of sexual dysfunction typically speaking
we're both parents at virgin just
because you have nothing to compare it
to that may or may not be true but at
the end the day people are more sexually
satisfied and that is because if you
have an open line of communication and
you are putting each other's needs first
if you waited to have sex until you're
married guess what sex will get better
yeah yeah your marriage now people
who've been playing the field
the idea is often like well you know I
had one guy say one time you know I've
been married for three years now so you
know I don't really have sex that often
you know what I mean I said it starts
off and you're naughty and it's taboo
and then you get married and that's old
hat but for people like us
it actually should get better because
you know you're figuring out the cheat
codes you're trying to hit the high
score
saltine you some women don't necessarily
have the same mindset especially if
you're coming at this from a Christian
perspective I will say there's been a
gross disservice done to a lot of young
Christian women where they don't talk
about sex a lot of their leaders a lot
of the their confidants don't really
talk about it because it's naughty or
it's dirty and you know what women want
to have sex too women want to have sex
within the confines typically speaking
as opposed to men who can you know they
can do it with the they can do with that
chair right it's got a nice it's got a
nice felt swatch is that a swell what is
with the textile you don't even need a
Gerald C well you don't even need any
form of friction it doesn't even have to
be the lure that's my point with a guy
it's pretty easy but women wanna have
sex too within the confines of
relationship where they feel secure and
they can trust the person not all women
there are exceptions yeah
maybe this isn't something that was
communicated to your with barring the
illness that's something that if you
knew like you said you saw the ride you
bought a ticket anyway going exactly
deal with but I do think there could be
some value in going to this is probably
the area finances and sex are the area
and communication but usually the
problems stem typically from
communication as they relate to finances
yes yeah yeah but finances and sex are
an area where marriage counselors like a
qualified psychologist who's a therapist
who works with couples can work wonders
as a matter of fact it's very rare that
it doesn't help so I highly recommend
that in this instance because your wife
may not feel comfortable and she may
feel as though you're prodding or you
are hopefully you're not prodding
against her well my point is
figuratively prodding yeah you want to
be like aliens poking in her body this
isn't a Ridley Scott see yeah the point
here is that I'm horribly sorry I just
get very uncomfortable these topics the
point is you may feel pressured by you
but not if it's an objective third party
who both of your best interests at heart
and I will say that often a lot of
people complain about couples counseling
how the therapist takes the side of the
woman often with sex it is usually more
illuminating for the woman and it ends
up yielding dividends it's something I
highly recommend as it relates to sex
communication finances one quick thing
through at the end here there's two
things one don't don't put sex on such a
pedestal that you think your life is
ruined if you don't have great sex with
your wife because there are situations
before
in a pedestal exactly I never want to do
that right it's tough don't make it that
hard do the other thing is a bit halt
sir serving one another sometimes your
wife and this is something that maybe
this counseling can help point out
sometimes she's not gonna feel like it
but because she loves you and wants to
serve you well she's going to have sex
and it may be the same you may be
exhausted you may not be in the mood for
anything but because she wants to and
you want to serve her well and you both
desire one another right sometimes you
have to do that and so it seems like a
little bit of that needs to take place
here yeah without knowing all the
information I definitely would recommend
some kind of counseling all right we are
coming up on this so I'm gonna put this
here some of the other ones we have is
for another life
ooh and I will advise for the light with
the last one here dear master guru
Crowder
Gerald a you've got that right that's
good thank God they sent it in on the
right day where you didn't take another
one vacation because apparently
frivolity is more important than
voluntary and quarter black black all
right my problem my husband has dated
almost strictly redheads ha I was blonde
when we started dating but dyed my hair
red in University it was my rebellious
stage I grew up in a conservative house
where I was not allowed to dye my hair
so you went with red and red yeah so you
know what's really gonna piss off my
parents the opie look windy all the
colors you chose red they came home my
husband found pictures when I was a
redhead and immediately started showing
everyone and tried to get everyone to
pressure me to dye my hair red I refused
to at first and told him it was never
going to happen fast forward to five
years later and we were married for just
over a year I continued to get harassed
by him to dye my hair red and he has
tried many times over the years to
convince my hairdressers to dye my hair
red I finally decided why not and dyed
my hair red after five years of him
bugging me have I played into his red
head fetish yes am i causing him to
stumble by having done this not
necessarily I was blond when we got
married so technically he married a
blonde my natural color but now that I'm
a redhead again it's hard to dye my hair
back
and I kind of like it okay he likes your
hair red that's not a problem that being
said I have talked about this many times
blonde brunette that's a preference
redhead is a fetish I don't know what it
is people but only a redhead will do I
have an aunt who is a complete redhead
one of my best friends in high school
had a little sister who was a redhead
and for some reason people think that
all boundaries go away when a man who
likes redheads encounters a redheaded
woman and that's where the catcalling is
really uncomfortable that my best friend
had is we have the same French teacher
and then he had his little sister the
next year he's an all men Blanc Hernan
on a Sarah name said oh she's got that
beautiful fiery red hair she's 15 he
will come up to my aunt and be like oh
my gosh just that hit what I wouldn't do
with someone without those kinds of
locks and I get they think they're being
complimentary but it's creepy there's
been blonde brunette peers like blondes
can date brunettes you who like
brunettes can de Blanc my preference
often was brunette but I've mostly dated
blondes but people who like redheads
only a redhead will do period end of
story and it's weird it's very weird
because it's a recessive gene it so just
go with a mutation yeah it seems like
she's being a little prideful here like
I know I I'm blonde and you married a
blonde actually I'd like my hair red but
I don't think I she was trying to
convince her hair stylist unbeknownst to
her come on have you ever seen a woman's
hair being dyed it can't happen on
accident she'll know something is going
she's getting highlights okay like she
should have a dubstep CD wouldn't it
wouldn't happen I think it has more I
think it was more sarcastic like he was
you know jokingly trying he probably
wanted it but what's the problem with
that if he's saying hey I would really I
see a picture of you having red hair you
say you liked red hair I think it would
be fun if you dyed your hair red but be
able to go back and forth if you like it
9:15 I see it would be okay it would be
a problem for example there is all of
this sort of you know this is this sort
of Game of Thrones behind the scenes
where you know and you can dye her hair
red unbeknownst to yes yeah
and if you guys had an inactive sex life
or something where you seem like they do
now are you because red hair that might
have been a problem but it seems to me
like he was attracted to you when you
were bloody married doing our lawn
yet he just liked your hair red yeah I
have certain ways that I like my wife to
do her hair and sometimes that's
different sometimes women like to do
their hair in a way that impresses other
women but men don't really like yeah
yeah it's lost on us
she's like straightens your hair and
does so much you know she's like you
don't like it's kind of wispy she what I
mean wispy I just think it's nice when
you put it up which is easier for
someone that's easier for me so just do
that
so there are preferences for example I
didn't I'd never seen my wife and
glasses until a little bit then I went
oh hello the glasses glasses glasses
it's nice one nice thing glass is it an
accent
yeah so it's just sort of something that
he thinks make you it makes you look
sexier more attractive I don't think and
you enjoy your hair red yeah I wouldn't
make a big if she is fixating on it then
it could be a prominent might be a
problem if she goes back to blonde and
there's like some kind of tension she
would only do it just to make sure she
can go back to blonde she's like I'm
gonna go back to blonde I know I love
being a redhead I'm gonna go back to
blonde just to show him that I could go
back to just stop that's an ego thing
stop don't if you want to go back to
bond do it because if you're ready to
move on that's fine but if you're doing
it just to piss him off to show him I
can go back to blonde if I want to stop
the way I dress for my wife I don't care
what I wear I dress whatever my wife
likes yes
because I don't really care as long it's
a more change my style or look like that
you know as long as they're not all of a
sudden you know coming in assless chaps
if my wife says hey I like that no you
already wearing those before hey I like
those jeans on you or hey like that
shirt on you why would I ever not wear
it right like I will never wear this
Henley again you're not the boss of me
no it's stupid it's ego you'll get less
sex use why would you read that for your
spouse right you should say what will my
spouse think is most attractive and
still obviously be your own person but
don't let ego enter the equation if you
don't like being a redhead and change it
to blonde and if your husband doesn't
love you anymore
that's a problem doesn't sound like
that's what's going on here I wouldn't
make a big deal about it and I would
show him that redhead
our fiery and do all kinds of weird
stuff well there you go whoops I mean
you know like baked like you know like
like add like an oatmeal raisin but like
like a filbert oh that's weird live life
on the wild side or maybe a Brazil you
know what I mean
maybe like you could put like a like or
maybe you make like a pecan pie but you
try with cashews you don't it's not and
do it in nothing but an apron that's my
point
thank you so much this has been a life
advice I am your guru
until next time with Guru Crowder